[Music]
go to hell all these horrible things are
private
[Music]
cannot go to this Hawaii is my Hawaii
the meaning of malama honua really is
mallamma need to care for something to
cherish something
who knew ah he translated from our
language beings our earth in a deeper
sense malama Honua is about caring for
that into earth where you come from
wherever that face is that you call home
it breaks my heart that our island here
just like a filter for all this plastic
pollution which in the ocean using a lot
of its winding up in Hawaii
plus the currents the whole world that
is throwing away five
a water bottle a stick packages netting
a stencil sort of a car
we also found black styrofoam people why
throw away over 50,000 pounds of
polystyrene of styrofoam
every single day Hawaii NC is the
highest per capita user of styrofoam
next to impossible to recycle styrofoam
is just economically in vehicle reason
why it's so detrimental is it finds its
way up the ocean food chain is all my
mother's food and they get not only the
styrofoam from their bodies like
chemicals that have been absorbed onto
it we do suspect that have a styrofoam
the paternal follows plastic it can get
caught in the intestines that can block
foods that can cause the turtle starve
to death
avocados got to get food for their
chicks they come back and dance the
plastic to their chick and the chicks
die from having all the plastic in the
stomach that is real food this all comes
from albatross energy teaming up this is
- Wow exist is this right
and in August amount of food
[Music]
so what we choose to do is really going
to determine what our future is going to
be like whether you get to see posting
photos whether you get to see a healthy
option
we can do something about this this soon
will be our world and we're going to
have to be protected the man set the
styrofoam is actually used in
Saeko foxes there's no reason to have
circles all of this detox for snobs like
months if you don't have a new styrofoam
nonsense late lunch is if it's cheap if
it tastes good and you can take it away
it all comes back to us it's really
important to make new decisions and
change our communities we here are the
[Music]
whether you're from Hawaii whether
you're from Miami Florida we're all
connected on this place that we all call
home and it's up to each one of us
wherever we are care for that place if
our responsible
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]